Ever since Inside Out came out, Pixar fans
have been trying to find where all the times
the Pizza Planet Truck appears in the movie.
Director Pete Docter said this particular
Pixar easter egg regular pops up 3 times,
but he also said it's so hard to see that
he challenged us Pixar fans to find it!
There was a tweet that suggested it appeared
in the background of San Francisco and Chinatown.
Now, I've scoured those scenes and could only
find a few trucks that looked similar to the
Pizza Planet truck but they didn't clearly
have the rocket on the roof.
So, I decided to take a look at some of the
scenes in the memory again, and I've found
not just three, but four appearances in three
scenes!
Let's take a look at where they crop up!
The first time the truck makes an appearance
is around 37 minutes into the movie, when
Joy spots Riley's imaginary friend Bing Bong
for the first time and, as he runs away, a
memory ball featuring the Pizza Planet Truck
falls to the floor and rolls along.
By the way, Pixar have confirmed this is definitely
the truck!
We see the truck for a second time about 45
minutes into the movie.
This time it appears during Riley's ice hockey
game.
In this scene, we actually see the truck twice;
first up we see it in a memory ball when Riley
begins to play hockey; and we see it again
in a memory ball after Riley falls down while
taking a shot and Anger starts to explode.
The last time we see the truck is in a memory
ball on the Train of Thought.
Joy, Sadness, and Bing Bong are trying to
make their way back to Headquarters on the
Train, and while Joy and Sadness are talking,
Bing Bong is examining memory balls in a box,
and for a moment he even picks up the one
with the Pizza Planet Truck in it .
Oh, by the way, I didn't mention this one
earlier as I'm not a 100% sure about it, so
let me know what you think, but could this
be another appearance of the truck in the
scene where Joy runs after Bing Bong?
Or is it just Riley's family car?
What do you see?!
So, guys, did you send yourselves cross-eyed
trying to find the Pizza Planet Truck in Inside
Out?
And who's your favourite character in any
Pixar movie?
You can check out my Top 10 Easter Eggs In
Inside Out and 25 Things You Probably Didn't
Know About Inside Out here.
And if you'd like to see more videos like
this, hit that subscribe button!
The next Pixar movie I'll be making a video
about is The Good Dinosaur.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!